cake what does it mean
what does it stand for no one knows
throughout the ages we've asked
ourselves these questions
we've seen cave paintings of cake on the
walls
back into the early eras of bc
before cake but how you ask yourselves
how
can there be cake before cake well we're
here to answer that question
we you ask oh you mean we
yes it's true we are the three cake
skateers and we are here to conquer cake
once and for all
introducing tyler the ethan shine
and ethan the tyler shide
together they make typhon
tyler the [ __ ] boy
and then ethan
the manly man investor this is the best
joke you've ever told
thank you and then me amongst these
titans of cakes
if you flip around the words of mark
what does it spell
cram as in
cram and here we stand
making cake are you ready fuckboy
are you ready manly man we have
cake ingredients you may not believe it
but in this form
inert ingredients shall combine to
become
cake but we know not the recipe before
it was lost
back in the times before cake but we
will redeem ourselves and we will bring
back the recipe from the precipice of
destruction through only our sheer wits
and our sheer spoons
we shall get this done and we shall do
this done
and to the end of our days we shall do
it to the doneness
of that it which is done
let's begin shall we so here's the rules
we have the ingredients here but we know
not the recipe we have to use our wits
and our minds and our spoons and our
buckets to be able to make the perfect
cake that we want to make and then we
put it in this
and then we put it in that and then for
an unknown number of time
we let it cook so how shall we do this
with our minds
and our guts some of this
three two one do we have a timer go
okay oh god pure [ __ ] luck at this
point
the first step is to whisk the eggs into
a nice
fluffy i don't need the yolks
where are you going i just realized
isn't that right
i have no idea if that's right but
something tells me i don't need the
[ __ ] yolks
oh my god why don't i need why am i
believing this ah i've watched so much
chopped that's good enough oh it's too
much
be free we don't have any utensils to
cut things with
we're just gonna have to take a little
bit how much time we got
oh my god you're about halfway through
oh my god
this butter is not gonna make it it's
not soft it's not gonna mix
oh melt with
[Music]
hell yeah it's totally enough you didn't
get milk you stupid loser
do we need water
[Music]
i think maybe
everybody's so mad
that seems like a logical component oh
you copier
excuse me i know the recipe for cake
i just know that the water is the last
step
a little bit more flour because it's a
little too soupy oh little final mix
oh [ __ ] that was too much
all right put your spoons down move down
i think we've cracked the codes
gentlemen i think we've cracked the code
oh yes mm-hmm yes
good that's a good consistency dude
thank you my butter is so chunky
so you can't mix any you cannot mix
any more what you have goes in your pan
so now that we've got our
cake mixes we need to put it on our pans
shall we stop get that nice and oh
yeah oh that's a good constancy
oh i think my whoa you've got dumplings
in here
the butter would not melt oh mine did
fine thank you wow yours is so smooth
this is so smooth yours is
not at all smooth mine's mine's
just right now let's just put it in
i'm going to come over for a sweet
action that's my slogan oh
um we didn't move the racks i think
it'll fit
yeah it'll fit why does that smell toxic
all right i'm just going to put mine in
you guys push mine back
and fit it all right so now we
wait
[Music]
what are you doing
[Music]
graham
oh i just got a psychic vision
the cake is alive and it's time for me
to pull mine
i think maybe i'm guessing ah yes
yours is that doesn't even look remotely
done no
ethan's is wonderful you know what i'm
gonna i'm gonna pull mine
um as per usual with these competitions
they're
judged on uh the the consistency of it
the overall presentation and the taste
so the cakey nature
how it looks and how it tastes just
going by how it looks
i win you have a you have a face
it's a man screaming cuz he's on fire
it's alive yeah so the first challenge
is going to be getting it not a goddamn
pan
so let's see oh boy
fine you're fine so we've got
10 minutes ish to decorate these cakes
in whatever way we see
fit and that time starts in three
two one go
just gonna scrape this off excuse me may
i have the trash
oh boy not doing too hot i'm doing great
no i'm just oh boy
like you know oh you can fill it with
something
maybe oh it's so lard like
so what i'm trying to do is i'm trying
to salvage uh
the the actually cooked part of the cake
oh you
you losers you left the buttercream to
me ah
everything can be made better with
buttercream don't worry so what i'm
trying to do is i'm trying to uh
enhance the uh the natural flavor of my
donut now
um with as much buttercream as humanly
possible because if i know these judges
they love themselves some buttercream
it's their favorite yeah it's their
favorite
and no i'm not gonna pander with my cake
i'm gonna make the cake that i would
want to eat
and therefore i am superior morally
something like that some [ __ ] like
that
oh this
is the color i didn't realize that
this is so relaxing that's why i love
these videos
because they're just very calm very no
pressure
[Music]
yeah time 10 seconds
[Music]
there was no countdown was it one good
second yeah i expected like
an instagram star no there was
chocolate this whole
[ __ ] what
oh you haven't seen it yet
[Music]
i was trying to make brown and i forgot
there was chocolate fudge icing
i gotta say yours has got style though
do you really like tyler you got
your brain choice he's the only person
who died anything yeah true
i didn't want to i don't want to take
the time that's a really good color
it's uh the consistency of the cake
itself
uh it is the overall taste and it's
presentation
i gotta say guys i got a whole load of
presentation
here no because you're digging
i would say it's a it's a patriotic
glory
i think i think that's um uncle sam
right in the middle
you know the patriotic glory that's what
i'm gonna call this one
the patriotic glory hole uh so my cake
uh turned out i mean from what it looks
like pretty well
baked um and then uh
it was amy's birthday recently so i was
like hey wanna make
amy birthday cake did you have birthday
cake i didn't have a birthday cake
well you do now pandering panda ring
you know amy loves america
[Laughter]
mine is attack of the worms
so instead of of taking on the
the burden of the gaping butter filled
holes that i had
i let the worms go ahead and eat away at
the butter and come through and attack
the planet that sentence was so sexual
i am turned on anyway go on about your
gaping holes and coming through
worms are coming out of the cake there's
mud holes and grass and plenty of
animals around
cool
[Music]
what was that what was that i missed it
i wasn't looking
i saw something
it's like a weird web shut off his mouth
did it get all my cake
i have to eat that what was what did you
do
look i didn't see it never seen anything
like that in my life
i've been wanting to figure out how to
do that in my entire life and i
accidentally do it all the time it's
called
leaking yes
is gleaking like spit through your teeth
no you don't spit through your teeth
it's squeezing your salivary glands to
where
it just shoots your saliva spray what
have you
tried it
why'd you do that
i had never done that in my life
today
i didn't try to do it it happened
somehow and i don't know how i did it
ladies i'm so sorry
i can't say it's on this half i don't
think it reached over
yeah i think you're safe on the southern
edge here i made the best out of a bad
situation right that's the thing
i can see like it kind of leaking in
there and it's not like this weird
moisture
ignore it ignore that side this side
where it's away from the spit
down here you got it you're gonna have
to taste that you're gonna have to taste
this
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know how to describe that
soapy
kind of i don't want to eat this one so
it's just the southern hemisphere just
like this section here
and you have to throw up just throw up
right in the hole
you hear the crunch well you chose to
get the burnt
above it i was thinking i chose that i
chose in my
drawer i told you in the middle here in
the middle really smart frosting to cake
ratio
you barely changed the cake
i taste worm which is delicious does it
taste like cake yes damn
oh martin's delicious mine is amazing
on the inside
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
good we made four decisions four
four decisions decisions uh for cake
batter
like the actual cake we just had no one
oh no no one a lot of them are very
cakey what
no okay mine's kind of cute cake cake
like
we went with tyler right yeah
yeah just because it had the least
offensive flavor
oh which is surprising yeah considering
the
butter holes oh no because i i feel sad
a little heartbroken
or had the proportions right the butter
just didn't get burnt at all
so you couldn't really taste the bad
yeah it burnt yeah decoration
yeah we did mark yay
yeah that's the one thanks was it
the glory hole or the patriotism both
the whole thing yeah i think you still
would have taken that category without
the dick
oh yeah all right girl winner is
ethan you did not excel at particularly
anything but we were the same solid
across the board if i had to keep eating
one i feel like yours is the least
likely to kill me okay that's fair
yeah we each want a category i think
that's good so we can take that home and
uh if you guys want to make cake at home
please for the love of god look at the
recipe don't undercook it
you can die we're probably gonna die now
we all
ate mine and either way thank you
everybody so much for watching send us
pictures of your cakes
and as always we will see you in the
next video
bye-bye